BLAIR: Right. Well first of all, Morgan, I've--
I mean, when you are the leader of the
country, I think you've got to be the leader of the
whole country,
so you can't take the narrow view of--
you can't say, "Look, this-- my--
whatever the policy is, my church overrides,
you know, the policy
that I think is in the interests of the country. Though
I think
the difficult thing here is that-- that--
actually, your religious views always,
of course,
color your approach to many
problems, and probably I would not have taken the
same
attitude to the debt campaign if I
hadn't personally been involved in that church movement.
But that doesn't mean that-- but what you can't
do then is surrender your--
you know, your--
as it were,
your duty to do what you think is
right and correct and represent the whole
country to your religion.
Now people always think religious people may
do that, but actually, genuinely, they--
usually they don't. In fact,
when the governor--
I think it was Al Smith who was the first Catholic
ever to stand as a presidential candidate.
When he ran for office--
I think it was the end of the 20s,
maybe? But
anyway, there was this
big-- big campaign that the
Pope was gonna move opposite the White
House, and
you know, he was therefore--
and I remember, because my wife is a Catholic--
before the 1997 campaign,
the Reverend Ian
Paisley suggested thatbecause my wife's
allegiance was to Rome, that she couldn't--
you know, I wouldn't really be
fit to
run the country-- and I remember I was so--
"Rome? What the--
she got some Italian connection I don't know
about?"
But actually what he meant was-- so, I think
you've got to be careful of that.
And the reason-- yeah, the reason,
frankly, I didn't, uh,
convert to Catholicism when I was Prime Minister
was just-- look, I had enough issues without
lighting that one into all the others.
So, I decided to do it afterwards. But I think,
you know, as a political leader,
you've got to represent-- in a pluralist
society, you've got to be able,
genuinely, to represent
the whole of the country.
I think, in relation to what Joe was saying--
I'm not sure about this, actually. I think
there are overlapping principles,
'cause I think,
you know, both the lady with the placard and Barney Frank
kind of accept that,
in the end, they're both
part of the constitution. I think one of the
real strengths of America
is this
idea that there is indeed a common space that
everyone is-- is in.
I mean, one of the things you find--
really interesting out in the Middle East
is when you explain to people
in certain countries in the Middle East that
as a Muslim, you can worship in America.
Because people actually--
I've had people say to me,
"No, not America." You say, "No, it's-- millions
of Muslims, you've got mosques in America." "Nah, nah."
And it's really, you know-- I think-- but that's
because, actually, it's just taken for granted, actually--
this is--
that in fact these principles do
overlap,
even with the most extreme people. And I think
that's a very, very important part of a functioning
society. Very, very important part and not
to be given up lightly. At all.
It's something that's
desperately important. I was explaining
to people earlier today how
one of the issues I had to tackle when I was Prime
Minister was that there were second generation
immigrants
who would come into the UK and decide that they--
and still couldn't speak English.
Second generation.
And my view in the end was
actually-- they--
it was part of the social obligation to do
this.
Because otherwise we weren't cohesive
as a society. Now,
on one level, that's an interference with someone's
freedom. But on another level,
you need to create that common space.
And you're right, also, that it evolves over
time. Of course it does. This is why any
religious belief, actually, that is static--
in other words,
takes no account of its historical setting
is,
I'm afraid, wrong in the end. And it just-- because
time evolves.
You know, in Christian times, there were slaves.
St. Paul wrote
about slaves having to,
you know, obviously to-- to accept the authority
of their masters. Now, there's a discourse there
that in our time time would be completely--
considered completely absurd and unacceptable.
But that's the way it is. But I think
that the value of having
this concept of the common space
is that it allows that evolution to happen.
And for that space also to be enlarged and changed
over time.
And Amanda, just finally on your point--
'cause Stephanie, you were asking to--
well, I think
if the state
could make that provision-- no, I think
that the religious groups wouldn't have to
fill the gap.
But I think what's
fascinating and important
is that they have filled the gap.
And they feel that because people were inspired
by their religious belief.
And that's why I think that-- that
this-- as I say, I think
the interesting thing about this whole debate
is that it's
often put in terms of, "Religious people
must accept that they can't
decide what happens, as it were, just by
virtue of their belief."
But in actual fact I think
every bit as interesting--
which is the reason why
Nicholas's response
to a lot of what was there-- is that
also, people who are non-religious
should be open enough to the religious to
accept that there are certain
ideas and thoughts and values that actually
can enrich society as a result of that religious
belief, even if you decide,
"I'm not a person of faith myself."
WOLTERSTORFF: Let's
let the other questions get raised. Just one
quick response to what Tony said.
The the fact that the Muslims in the Middle
East find it incredible that-- when you
say to them that
as as a Muslim you can worship in the US--
that just reinforces
the analysis I gave, that-- that
the way we have structured religion in the state
is truly extraordinary, and most people
find it
difficult to believe. "What do you
mean that
that all the religions are treated equally? What?"
Extremely difficult to believe.
And we forget what a risky experiment it was
250 years ago. Had never been
tried, and I think what's behind the Habermas
quotation is--
well, I mean, Habermas and
McEntire also think of the state as just like
a telephone company and so forth, a huge bureaucracy--
but it's this nostalgic longing for
once upon a time,
the state was the highest expression of a
morally, religiously unified citizenry.
Now that's gone. And it's just into managements.
I think that's--
the nostalgia, that's putting it from the
dark frightening side, but James Madison,
above all, said,
"It has to be tried."